a lot of news today and to start with
things are not going particularly well
for the President of the United States
we've now learned that the White House a
number of White House advisors have
started to warn the president about the
possibility of the impeachment process
starting against him that he could
potentially face at some point in the
next we don't really know how long these
things can take a long time and what we
can be sure of is that if Donald Trump
were to be the target of impeachment
proceedings it would be the greatest
impeachment ever right folks I mean we
would have the best articles of
impeachment of any administration Bar
None not like the failing fake news
media would have written about a
potential Barack Obama impeachment we
would really have the biggest and best
in people impeachment of all if it were
to happen under Donald Trump and we're
seeing advisers warn Trump or prepare
Trump for this in the wake of a trump
agenda which despite being bogus to
begin with doesn't really matter has
completely stalled the Russia
investigation is not going particularly
well for Trump every week some new
aspect of the potential collusion and
cover up leaks approval ratings for
Trump basically at this point stuck
between 35 and 37 percent and now
according to the Washington Post in
Newsweek it is not just one but multiple
White House advisors who have been
talking to the president about the
potential for impeachment and how that
process would go and Donald Trump has
been scaling up the sort of antagonism
against Republicans and over the last
month or so we've seen everything from
the direct attacks on Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell to a couple of
other more general tweets targeting
Republicans starting first with one
where Donald Trump said it's very sad
that Republicans even some that were
carried over the line on my back do very
little to protect their president Donald
Trump also tweeting late in July if
Republicans don't repeal and replace the
disastrous Obama care the repercussions
will be far greater than any of them
understand we have to break this down
into a few
different elements number one if Trump
ever thought that his agenda was going
to pass with the help of Democrats he
was obviously operating in a fantasy
world but now we're talking about Trump
going after Republicans saying hey some
of you are here because of me may be
true in some cases definitely not true
in others you'd better help me advance
my agenda and this is something that
we've talked about almost from day one
really which is Republicans don't seem
to be particularly ideologically tied to
supporting Donald Trump it's more how it
will affect their reelection chances and
when it comes to impeachment do you
think Donald Trump really even
understands the potential of being
impeached or just his delusional ego
sort of preclude him from thinking
something like that could even possibly
happen after all how could the best deal
maker in history ever end up in a
situation where he might be impeached
you know Donald Trump was impeached it
wouldn't just be from Democrats you'd
have to get some Republicans to go along
with that doubt and when he you know
specifically targets senators like John
McCain and Jeff Flake and talked about
maybe primary challenging them going
after the leader of the Senate
Republicans Mitch McConnell it's just
poor strategy because I think you have
to hold on to at least you know all but
19 of those Republican senators to keep
yourself in power it's really you when
you look at the numbers this Pat is sort
of pointing out ultimately if there is
going to be impeachment of Donald Trump
it's going to depend on Republicans and
I wonder if that could really happen I
mean would Republicans do it why would
even if you're a Republican in the House
or Senate and you don't particularly
care for Trump's brand of so called the
republicanism which is really not it's
really just incompetence and ignorance
thinly veiled in populist rhetoric
actually with authoritarian tendencies
why would a Republican Congress for
example impeach Trump when they can keep
him and keep the attention on his
scandals and get all of their bills
rubber stamped by Trump yes
Trump does some things that Republicans
don't like but overall Trump does
provide Republicans cover to do mostly
whatever it is that they want only if
their re-election chances are at stake
would they really consider
Pietschmann and then the other thing and
we're thinking ahead here Democrats also
need to think about whether impeachment
is the best move because that could put
Mike Pence and Paul Ryan in charge of
the Republican Party and I've said this
before isn't the best solution that
Donald Trump stays riddled with scandal
and unable to really accomplish anything
until 2020 I I know we keep going back
to this Pat but you could actually see
Republicans accomplish much more if
Donald Trump is impeached and I I don't
think that that is some crazy conspiracy
theory I think that that's something
Democrats really need to be thinking
seriously about the issue that the
Republican Party is facing is that
there's such an ideological gap in
between the conservatives and the
moderates and sometimes it's hard to
bridge that gap and regardless of if
Trump or Pence's and power I don't know
if they're going to be able to
consolidate their message and get what
they want past in that Congress that's
interesting there might be something to
that I mean we've talked about what I
see as the three divisions of the
Republican Party are sort of the MIT
Romney type low tax pro-business that
wing of the Republican Party
you've got the religious conservatives
which interesting interestingly enough
still a plurality voted for Donald Trump
during during the Republican primary
which was quite shocking and then you've
got the more Tea Party anti-government
types and I think the health care repeal
debacle is a good example of how
Republicans are not united and when you
don't have a polarizing figure like
Trump I do believe that they would be
able to get more on the same page
because Donald Trump doesn't really fit
into any three of those categories and I
think that we will we will have to wait
and see ultimately what happens with
this but I do believe that Democrats
need to be careful about what they wish
for because it could also end up not
going particularly well for them the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership